[Music]
Arecibo Observatory Puerto Rico 45 years
ago it sent a powerful radio message
deep into space kick-starting our
efforts to make first contact the
editable message was the first
communication or attempt to communicate
with a possible civilization out there
in the galaxy or outside of nor galaxy
today that message is speeding towards
the m13 galaxy cluster 25,000
light-years away it contains information
about our world where we are even the
makeup of our DNA the purpose of this
message was of course like trying to say
hi and also like to light up this
question about are we alone in the
universe
[Music]
but what chances are there that an
intelligent alien race is out there
waiting to receive our message do I
think there's other intelligent life out
there in the universe the answers are
astounding yes yes I do we know that
life began on earth pretty much as soon
as our planets solidified so why
wouldn't that have happened somewhere
else if life has evolved on other worlds
just how many alien civilizations are
out there that we could potentially
contact
astronomer Frank Drake developed an
equation to help answer this crucial
question the Drake Equation is a really
admirable attempt to apply some
quantitative reasoning to the
probability or the possibility that
there is life beyond the earth you
multiply the star formation rate for
stars in our galaxy x the number of
planets that each star has times the
probability that you would have life
forming on that planet times the
probability that that life form becomes
intelligent and they estimated that
there were about 10,000 intelligent
civilizations within our galaxy
since the Drake Equation was first
proposed our understanding of the galaxy
has radically transformed we have now
discovered worlds outside our solar
system exoplanets
exoplanets are being discovered all over
the place there are about 4000 of them
now noun and techniques are finding more
every day
scientists believe what we found is the
tip of the iceberg
[Music]
so if the cosmos is so good at making
planets perhaps it can produce the
conditions to make life throughout the
universe when the Drake Equation was
devised all those decades ago we didn't
know that exoplanets existed and now we
need to think that there are quite
literally more planets than there are
stars in the universe so even if life is
really rare there are an enormous number
of chances for it to take hold in the
universe and for this reason it is very
likely that there is life relatively
abundant in the universe including an
uncountable number of advanced alien
civilizations this isn't science fiction
it's just basic probability
probabilities suggest a multitude of
alien civilizations are out there so
isn't it a little strange
we haven't made first contact I think
there's every reason to believe that
there are civilizations out there but we
have no evidence of them yet why haven't
we found other civilizations out there
one answer could be the sheer vastness
of the cosmos look at all these lights
out here over this cityscape you can
think of these lights is like stars in
the galaxy now if there's 10,000
communicating civilizations out there in
the galaxy you might think oh man look
there's one right there right down the
street the problem is there are hundreds
of billions of stars in the galaxy
which means that maybe our nearest
neighbor that we can communicate with is
not right there but way across the city
we live in the suburbs of the Milky Way
75,000 late years from the farthest edge
radio signals travel at the speed of
light
[Music]
this speed limit means that any signal
sent to the opposite side of the galaxy
would take 75,000 years to reach its
destination the thing you have to
remember is the galaxy is gigantic even
if there are 10,000 civilizations in the
galaxy it's possible that the distances
between stars are just so huge that
we're never going to be able communicate
with each other so the
forty-five-year-old Arecibo radio
message could still be tens of thousands
of years away from any potential alien
civilization the target was 25,000
light-years from here the message is now
45 light-years from here because it's
traveling the speed of light so it's
really far from the target
the vast size of the universe is a huge
roadblock to making first contact and
the laws of physics prevent radio
signals from overcoming it you just
cannot go faster than the speed of light
so our galaxy may be filled with life
filled with civilizations but they're so
far away I don't want to be the bearer
of bad news but the universe is just
really really far too large the universe
may be large but we're putting the most
advanced technology on earth into action
to try and speed up the search
there really is a serious scientifically
valid way to go looking for other
civilizations and the breakthrough
listen project is really the best thing
we have right now state-of-the-art
facilities around the world radio
telescopes optical telescopes as well
are all looking up to the sky together
break through listen is targeting the 1
million stars and 100 galaxies closest
to Earth it is the most comprehensive
search for alien communications ever
undertaken
if there was an aircraft giving off a
radar signal and that aircraft was
around any of the 1,000 nearest stars
the breakthrough listen project could
hear that so if there's something out
there that's actually giving off a
signal breakthrough listen has a chance
to find it breakthrough has started by
listening in on the nearest 1700 stars
to earth so far silence this is the
wonderfully beautifully frustrating
position that we find ourselves in we
haven't heard anything yet so we're in
this position where a negative result
doesn't mean there aren't civilizations
but we have no proof that there are
breakthrough listen is just beginning
its hunt there's much more real estate
in the cosmos for it to search it's a
big job demanding a lot of patience if
you go through Drake's equation and find
this number of 10,000 intelligent
civilizations out there there are
something like 250 billion stars in the
galaxy so that's only one civilization
for 25 million stars that's a lot of
cold calling
the size of our universe means we could
be waiting a very long time to pick up
any alien communication but even if we
pick up a signal it may have arrived too
late if we do receive a message given
that it probably took years to get here
that civilization could be long gone so
are we simply too late have any aliens
out there already died out